[Music]
mama said I will always be
paid the stronger my love is me
caught her crying and praying on her
knees
mama said I will always be
[Music]
Winter Falls in summer instruments
we're changing my pages
Ecclesiastes we lose power when I'm
pretty
[Music]
as my house can't see
as my eyes can't see
that's my eyes can't see
[Music]
as my house can't see
oh
Monty Jones didn't race though
[Music]
no food was still so full
as my house can't see
it's my house can't see
[Music]
as my house can't see
as my eyes can't see
[Music]
Jesus will change but I pray you keep my
name
whatever it means pray to God you stay
the same
as my eyes can't see
[Music]
as my high skin
as my house Casey
[Music]
as my eyes can't see
foreign
[Applause]